season three of the loud house is under
way and fans are thrilled but they also
found a few potholes and mistakes in the
newest episodes the last should
definitely be illegal if you like
animated shows as much as we do
subscribe to the things channel for
up-to-date videos and click on that
thumbs up button if you love the loud
house now check out ten mistakes in the
loud house season three you might have
missed air guitar in roadie to know
where loon allowed learns that she's
going to be headlining the Royal Rumble
she is super stoked that is until she
finds out that her roadie chunk had
aspirations of becoming a huge rock star
too and that he also headlined the
rumble when he was in school this
crushes Lunas dreams she begins to worry
that she's gonna wind up like chunk who
lives in his van and collects junk off
of the side of the road but Lunas got
some insane guitar skills for audition
to perform at the Royal Rumble is pretty
epic at one point she even plays two
guitars at the same time but we noticed
something a little odd during the song
she lifts both hands in the air we can
still hear guitar music playing even
though both of her hands are up in the
air
oops how can she play guitar with no
hands that takes the air guitar thing to
a whole new level
don't you think of course we get that
this would just be a minor animation
mistake we wouldn't even notice if we
weren't just huge fans of the show air
guitar not Lou allowed is one of our
favorites wardrobe malfunction in no
place like home school the loud kids are
jealous of the fact that Lola gets to be
homeschooled her siblings think that
home school is a breeze where you mostly
goof off all day and they want in on it
Lincoln convinces his parents to let him
be homeschooled as well their parents
agree on the condition that they all get
their work done on their own or it's
back to regular school Lola warns her
siblings not to wait into the last
minute to get their workbooks done but
do they listen of course not
they spend all week goofing around until
they realize they're gonna be tested to
make sure they haven't been slacking off
all week panicked they beg Lola to help
them study
Lola stayed up all night to help her
sibling study which made her too tired
to finish her own test
she failed Lola was almost sent back to
regular school until the gang convinced
the folks to give her a second chance
when Lola finds out she's in the hallway
wearing her pink gloves but when she
gives her siblings a group hug
her gloves are missing guess the idea of
homeschooling really knocked her gloves
off the working kindergartner we all
know that Lisa loud is super smart and
way too advanced for her age but she's
still a kid who can't work yes lisa is a
child prodigy who is constantly working
on strange experiments remember the time
she invented glowy o's which were Oreos
shaped cookies infused with jellyfish
DNA if people ate the cookies their
bodies would glow Lisa loves to solve
difficult math equations not to mention
she is constantly studying the DNA and
bathroom habits of her siblings it only
makes sense that a prestigious science
Institute would want to hire her that's
exactly what happens in the episode
titled the mad scientist Lisa sees this
job as an opportunity to get away from
her crazy family and cramped living
conditions for a while but hold on did
everybody forget how old Lisa is
according to the homeschooling episode
earlier in the season Lisa is a
kindergartner that would make her five
or six years old we know it's a cartoon
but it's still a bit far-fetched to
think she could be gainfully employed at
a Science Institute seriously there are
child labor laws against that sort of
thing Lisa is definitely brilliant but
she got at least 10 or 12 years to go
before she should get a real job the
white hair in the season 3 episode
titled the white hair Lincoln wants to
impress the new girl in town so he
decides to dress like a 1950's greaser
his sisters catch him trying to tiptoe
out of the house wearing a black leather
jacket and slicked back hair the girls
get excited and want to help him but he
refuses he doesn't want a repeat of the
last time they tried to help him which
was a disaster so he sets out on his own
to go to school while waiting for the
bus Lincoln decides to hide from his
sisters but that's where the first air
in the episode happens fans were quick
to point out that Lincoln usually walks
to and from school so why is he taking
the bus this time fans also pointed out
that when the rabbit warren ran from his
rabbit sisters the bunny who
the chase music on the guitars had a
dress that changed color from purple to
pink good catch someone else pointed out
in the previous episode Lincoln
convinced Lucy that the best way to
impress a guy was just to be herself now
he's the one who needs to learn that
lesson fool me twice and the episode
titled fool me twice it's April Fool's
Day in the loud family is dreading
Luann's relentless April Fool's Day
pranks so they did what any normal
family would do they hired stunt doubles
to take their place for the day so
Luanne would think she's pranking her
family but she's really pranking these
stunt doubles instead pretty clever
right the family believes this worked
for them until the wound reveals that
she knew all along they hired stunt
doubles so she had look-alikes go out
into the world and do embarrassing
things in front of their friends to
humiliate them but a fan pointed out a
plot hole in this story
how did Luanne find out they hired stunt
doubles once she found out how did she
convince the Devils to help her pull
these pranks regardless the family got
Luanne back in a pretty big way they
convinced the land that they sold the
house and are moving away because
they're so embarrassed they can never
show their faces in royal woods again
the land breaks down crying and swears
to never prank them again and they all
shout April Fool's even with the plot
hole it's pretty funny episode the
missing tray and roadie to know where
Lisa takes an electronic lift of to
Lunas bunk to do her weekly DNA cheek
swab Luna confides in Lisa that she's
worried about her future
she says that making it as a rock star
seems impossible but she can't seem to
find anywhere else she fits into the
music business
she tells Lisa she doesn't know what to
do and then it cuts to Lisa Lisa thinks
for a moment then pushes a button that
makes a chart pop out of her lifts she
advises Luna to take a practical
approach and tells her that according to
a National Labor Statistics study the
fastest growing fields are health care
food service and Technology
lisa has a lot of contraptions at our
disposal at any given time but we looked
closely and the trace she came in with
at the beginning of the scene just
vanished
where did the tray with the q-tips and
DNA kit go when we see Lisa after Luna
shares her struggle with the music
business the tray is nowhere in sight
it's possible that she had a gadget arm
take the tray and put it away but then
we would have heard the mechanical
sounds similar to the ones we heard
where the chart pops out it is all very
mysterious wait
what month is it so in the episode
called fandom pain
Lucy settles in to watch her favorite
show but much to Lucy's dismay her
sisters Laurie and Lennie want to watch
the show with her the reason they want
to watch the show is because they are in
love with a super hot actor named Blake
Bradley who is starring in the show as
one of the vampires great great great
great great grand nephews named Tristan
as the show ends Lucy is clearly annoyed
but Laurie and Lenny are thrilled and
want to watch the show every Friday with
Lucy Lucy tries to devise a plan to turn
them off from the show but it just makes
them more excited and more into it
here's the error fans found when the
girls are counting the days until the
next episode they show a calendar that
they are marking the calendar says April
but right before that the tree outside
has orange leaves on it indicating that
it's really fall the leaves usually
don't turn that color in April another
weird thing that fans pointed out is
that the calendar has 35 days on it
we're not trying to be picky but we're
pretty sure that's wrong the max number
of days in a month is 31 and April is
only supposed to have 30
oopsey fast healing foot and the episode
titled a fridge too far the kids are
fighting over the food they keep in the
fridge it all starts with the mac and
cheese bites that Lincoln has been
saving and obsessing about all day at
school when he gets home he realizes
that one of his siblings has helped
herself to his mac and cheese bites this
begins a battle of the fridge
Lincoln rigs the fridge to injure anyone
who goes after his mac and cheese bites
when LuAnn goes to steal Lincoln's food
she sets off a trap that drops a
watermelon out and breaks her foot for
the next few scenes after the incident
Louanne is in a cast and using crutches
but then magically a few scenes later
she is healed and the cast and crutches
are gone
we new cartoons like Tom and Jerry and
Wiley coyote and the roadrunner allow
for lightning-fast healing of injuries
but we didn't expect that from the loud
house Luanne seems to be walking around
just fine in no time we want the super
healing powers of those cartoon
characters maybe the loud house can team
up with the x-men and have a mutant
superhero movie we would watch that
disappearing reappearing catch up in the
episodes city slickers Lincoln and Lori
drive to the city together they both
have their own fantasies of being in the
city
Lori sees herself as a city girl while
Lincoln dreams of spending quality time
with Ronny and but things don't really
work out like they'd hope Lonnie Ann
doesn't want Lincoln to cramp her style
by talking about the time they spent
together in royal woods so every time he
talks she tries to stop him she even
went as far as to squirt a bunch of
ketchup on his shirt while they were at
the fountain eating hot dogs during the
scene fans noticed a pretty major
continuity error after she squirts a big
blob of ketchup on Lincoln's shirt it
cuts to a wider shot and the ketchup
stain has disappeared Lincoln did give
his shirt a quick wipe but there's no
way he could remove such a big ketchup
stain with such a little effort after
that she knocks him into the fountain
that would have been a believable time
to lose the ketchup stain also the
ketchup packet keeps disappearing and
reappearing that is some magical ketchup
these loud house fans do not miss a
thing
Rita her rights this episode starts with
Rita having a very hectic day which for
her is the same as every day she is so
busy shuttling the kids around to
various school events and sporting
activity she often forgets to read the
parking signs Rita gets another parking
ticket which for the parking officer
reminds her is her fifth paint violation
Rita opens her glove box to reveal that
it is stuffed to the max with parking
tickets she tries to explain to the
parking officer that she is busy with 11
kids that she sometimes doesn't even
notice the parking signs doesn't work
the officer doesn't care and gives her
yet another parking ticket Rita has to
do community service to pay off all
those tickets fans made a good point
about this one they said that if Rita
had really received all those parking
tickets she would definitely have a boot
on
wiill or worse van Zilla would have been
impounded well before she reached the
15th Ticket mark
oh well that's cartoons for you we still
love this show what mistakes have you
noticed in season three don't be shy
share them in the comments we promise
not to judge the show too harshly there
you have it for 10 mistakes in the loud
house season 3 you might have missed
thanks for watching the things bye
[Music]